welcome back fans of the Dark Horse
podcast we forgot to get drinks we
forgot to get drinks next time alright
we are here to follow up on our live
stream that just ended by answering your
super chat questions which have been
collected for us in a spreadsheet which
you can't see but we can there's some
good questions in here I'm looking for
there shall we get right to it let's do
it yeah
you want me to read them yeah if you
would alright can you talk a bit about
viral load please it is know that the
amount viral load is important of IRA
load is important in case of measles
chicken pox polio could it also be the
case with co19 thanks you know we talked
about this a bit in our last or maybe
maybe the third live stream not sure
which one but we specifically talked
about its seeming quite possible that
viral load does in fact repetition of
exposure increases the chance of getting
infected and dent viral load increases
the chance of becoming very very sick
there are some you know possible caveats
which is for instance that health
workers have other extenuating factors
like tending to be overworked stressed
sleep-deprived cetera sure wearing blue
which is that'll be the topic of the
next live stream yeah wearing blue can
create create issues yeah so I think was
livestream three we talked about that
yeah so I think we effectively know
that viral load is playing an important
role the real question is why you know
what part of the system is being
overwhelmed such that somebody who's had
a low exposure might have a much more
mild disease or an asymptomatic one and
anyway that there's a mechanistic
question to be answered there which will
tell us a lot once we know the answer
anyway yeah so stay tuned good sayo
virus circulating inside a species is
lethal to some rivals or predators would
rivals turn away from a shared habitat
and predator from prey so I think this
is a restatement of a question that was
asked last time that you and we couldn't
quite fire student parse and I spent a
lot of time thinking about what that
question might have meant and I realized
not only did I understand what the
question was but that I had once a long
time ago asked Bob Trivers our
undergraduate advisor the very same
question really yes I had asked him the
very same question so the question
basically was could you be infected with
something that would work to your
benefit by dissuading things that might
eat you from wanting to so my example
years ago was pigs and trichinosis could
the trichinosis be preventative and
Bob's response was that he'd love to see
an analysis whereby it could work but
that it almost certainly wouldn't work
for reasons of group selection which I
didn't understand his answer at the time
because that was a new concept to me but
he made an argument in which he snow
because arguing effectively he was
arguing that the mechanism that I was
asking about would comet and clear
selection so without getting into that
madness right now let us just say that
the problem for a mechanism like this
where a creature takes on a virus that
maybe it tolerates well but its
predators won't and thereby its
predators decide not to eat it the
problem with that is that the best deal
of all goes to the creature who gets the
benefit of predators not eating that
type of animal but doesn't have the
virus so there's a question about how
you would provide an honest
advertisement that you actually had the
the
illness that the predator didn't want to
mess with of pathogenic mullerian
mimicry yeah so anyway I think it
doesn't work but it's not to say it that
there's not some system in which some
analog of this could work for reasons
that we would have to dispel out it
would run counter to Hamilton's ook
style analysis as well in which females
are imagined the hypothesis is that
females are looking for potential mates
for for males as potential mates who
have low pathogen load and who have some
external indicators some phenotypic
indicator of that low pathogen load so
these would be really competing
hypotheses you wouldn't you wouldn't
find both within the same population
true although I think implicit in the
the model would be that whatever the
particular pathogen was had such little
negative effect that females would have
no reason to care about it actually so
anyway I think the answer is no it
doesn't work but it doesn't mean that
something in the ballpark couldn't work
in some system yeah good you to a god
sense well thank you but the world is
missing a voice from your esteemed crew
Jordan Peterson his sparse tweets of
late don't sound like his voice and
people are dubious about their
authenticity in his physical health yeah
he's he's he's doing much better and he
has been quite sick and he is alive and
healing and I don't think it's really
our place to say much more than that but
I think the world will be hearing more
from him soon yeah I can say we're
worried about him obviously with what
he's been through in the last year he is
vulnerable here and I think it's very
important that he not come in contact
with Cove at 19 but we do hear that he
is getting better on the mend
in touch with him and if you're watching
Gordon hello we miss you we need your
voice and we will be thrilled when
you're ready to to return to the public
eye indeed all right really appreciate
you too making the effort to do this
it's fascinating thanks and be well
thank you
hydrocortisone vitamin C and thiamine
were used successfully to treat severe
sepsis and septic shock most SARS Kove
to die of it it being sepsis and septic
shock apparently any thoughts thank you
I'm doubtful about that claim I am too
I've heard and I haven't I haven't
actually heard the claims about
hydrocortisone or thiamine before I've
heard indicators that vitamin C as as a
well known and somewhat well understood
I think antioxidant has been somewhat
useful in treatment and my anecdotal
experience which has prompted me hearing
a bunch of other people's anecdotal
experience of people craving citrus when
they have been sick is suggestive that
there might be some some mechanism by
which vitamin C is useful in staving off
or in healing after infection and again
like I don't I don't know for sure that
I had it but it seems quite likely that
I did I don't I haven't heard
hydrocortisone is an anti-inflammatory
and we know we think we know that one of
the things going on with extreme cases
of co19 is inflammation where there
ought not be inflammation so there's at
least a simple possible relationship
there diamond I just don't know enough
about firemen to what about the question
of sepsis have you heard that most
people who are dying of kovat 19 die of
sepsis no that's the part I'm really yea
dubious about and I think the rest of
the question is dependent on that claim
being right so I think it is if there is
something to that claim show us what we
haven't seen yet we may have just
overlooked it yeah and you can probably
by tweeting something at one or both of
us it's the best way to try to show us
that you've talked about the limited
ability of tissues to self repair do you
think there might be a limit to the
number of times dendrites in the brain
can self repair after being damaged by
alcohol so there's again an assumption
in this that dendrites in particular
being damaged by alcohol consumption
obviously a lot of things are damaged by
alcohol consumption but I had not
independently heard about
Android's yeah I've heard it I'm not
sure how valid the claim is because the
problem is in dendrites we were talking
about the the extensions of the cell
body of a neuron and these connections
are basically the circuit the map of the
way neurons are connected to each other
so each neuron in the brain and the
point of the circuits that then and in
termina that synapse antenna news yeah
so you have a cell body with dendrites
taking inputs and then you have an axon
which extends off the cell body and then
it leads to these these termina which
then interface with I thought it was the
other way around I thought dendrites
were at the endpoint but no matter the
dendrites are on the on the cell body
and but anyway the point is the
interactions between the the dendrites
and the other cells to which they're
connected are effectively a data
processing mechanism and so the loss of
a dendrite isn't inherently good or bad
because the loss of a dendrite has to do
with changing the interface between the
the neuron and other neurons and so in
other words dendrites being lost is part
of how the brain gets wiser and more
effective other dendrites being lost
would be a loss of function but you
can't say one way or the other whether
it's inherently it's not inherently good
or bad so so let me just say this
reminds me of you know there are a lot
of kinds of programmed cell death and I
see a dendrite is a part of a cell but
in early development and humans for
instance you know we have hands that are
highly webbed and then you get this
apoptosis yeah in which we lose our
webbing and this is not you know that
loss of tissue could be viewed by
someone who doesn't know what the hand
is ultimately going to look like as a
problem but it's actually quite quite
the intention you know quite quite the
goal so loss of tissue is not inherently
yeah failure it's necessary in some
cases but in this case a you don't have
the reason for dendrites to have the
same limitation on the amount of
replication they can do
because there's no danger of your
there's no dendritic cancer where
dendrites proliferate so much that you
can't think or function so there's no
limit that's necessary on dendritic
growth also the simple fact of their
being present or absent isn't isn't
inherently good and so anyway I think
the answer to the question is no there's
no reason to expect an analog in
neuronal tissue of the limitations on
cellular replacement that occurs in the
rest of the body and indeed the the
programming of the brain is really about
how the neurons are wired primarily
rather you know which cells connect to
what rather than the growth of new
neuronal tissue okay is it possible the
ratios from studies using long tail
array mice might still hold some
validity since the controls are also
long telomeric mice somebody is paying
attention the answer is yes in some
circumstances it depends really what's
being tested there's no question that
there are many purposes for which a long
telomere Mouse may be a perfectly valid
study organism and then there are other
purposes for which it's an absurd study
organism and you have to be and there
are purposes for which we do not know
there are many purposes for which we do
not know and so anyway yeah sure they're
gonna be cases in which the fact of both
groups having long telomeres negates the
negative impact and there going to be
other cases where it accentuates
something and renders a paradoxical
result but we can't know how any of this
functions until we figure out what the
state of the mice is when it changed if
it changed by what means it changed and
we as far as we can tell that work isn't
being done or at least it's not being
acknowledged so we have a huge problem
but no it won't be across all studies oh
the other thing I wanted to say is we
saw earlier in the livestream that
preceded this question-and-answer we
were talking a little bit about the
question of
the blood of people who've had Kovac 19
being used to treat people who haven't
had it and having some sort of positive
effect and that we didn't know whether
that positive effect was from antibodies
that were successfully repelling the
virus or whether it could be a simple
matter of having intact hemoglobin
molecules in viable blood cells that
were replacing defective ones this is a
case in which you don't even know which
control to run right so do you want is
the control people who've never had
kovat 19 right or is the control plasma
versus blood so anyway there's a rich
question here about what the proper
control for the experiment is which is
entirely contingent on which question
you're asking okay could humanity's
technological acceleration be framed as
an evolutionary response to a near
extinction event such as the one
proposed by the Younger Dryas impact
hypothesis Clovis comment thanks for all
the streams so the Younger Dryas impact
hypothesis this this question I think
does not hinge on this but it's a it's
something from twelve thirty thousand
years ago that is thought to have been a
comet or asteroid that may have been
dispersed already before it impacted
then there are many many sites around
the earth that impact and may have
caused a long winter climate change
possibly the end of the Clovis culture
and a number of possible effects both
biotic and abiotic across the world
which you know in in that case
presumably did change you know the end
of the Clovis culture in the new world
would have opened up lots of niche for
other expansion you know adaptive
radiation of the humans who were in the
new world at that point for sure but I
think this question is asking about our
technological acceleration right now I
think and you know this this moment
potentially Tsarskoe of to being red is
a near extinction event or maybe the
Cold War or any you know any number of
things since the intestine
evolution perhaps well let's just say
there are a lot of ways that this can
work it's very hard to take a system
that seems to be functioning and to
argue for a radical shift which is where
we find ourselves at the present we have
to shift the way our system functions
because our system literally cannot
continue on this way there's just simply
not enough of the resources that we are
exhausting for us to keep doing this so
you've got cornucopia pnes who think
we'll come up with something and then
you've got people who know that that
process isn't reliable who are saying
well it doesn't matter that things are
going reasonably well we have to change
the way we live and the sooner we do it
the better very hard to make that
argument
you know this we're running up against
the problem of people like Steven Pinker
pointing out that it's never been better
here and the truth is in many ways it
has never been better
but that doesn't mean it's sustainable
and so if it's not sustainable the last
two matters
sorry until the last two months most
people in weird countries had never
imagined what it might be like to go to
a store and have empty shelves yeah so
anyway this is a long way of saying that
among the many mechanisms through which
a catastrophe of one kind or another can
promote change that's positive is that
it opens people's eyes so if people can
now understand that the system that we
are living in is hyper fragile and that
that means you can't just look at how
easy things are on your average day and
in for anything about how long it will
go on now we can have a discussion about
how to shore up the system and to
reasonably change it so that we can
continue living as we do for you know
two hundred five hundred a thousand
years into the future that's a
discussion that's much more possible in
light of kovat 19 and frankly as I've
said before this could have been we're
not out of the woods but this could have
been much much worse right and so anyway
there is as horrifying as this is there
is a positive aspect which is that we
are all now awake to the fragility of
the system in a way we just simply
weren't a couple of months ago that's
right the Steel Man podcast since every
purse
except thought sensation etc is
experienced in consciousness and there's
no capacity to go outside consciousness
to validate a physical substrate why
don't we talk about the hard problem of
material why don't we talk about the
hard problem material I think it's
because if we talked about the hard
problem in materialism nobody would want
to talk to us hey that's because we're
social creatures we Intuit that if we go
down that road we'll be very lonely
although to be fair I feel a little bit
that way about people who want to talk
about the hard problem of consciousness
I see I feel that way about them as well
so we're not really answering the
question but we can see for sure that
those organisms who are not sharing
their conscious thoughts and sensations
with us but are manifesting in the world
and doing things are experiencing their
world materially are engaging the world
materially whether or not they have
consciousness and whether or not they
can share that consciousness with us so
the hard part so this is I can't
remember what it's called this idea that
is gaining some traction in some circles
that consciousness precedes oh yeah
world whatever it's called it's Pam yeah
I think this this feels like I can't
tell if it's asked asking in sort of 9
good faith I think all of the Steelman
podcast questions are in good faith but
is it is it a jab at pants psychism or
is it an attempt to get us to engage it
I'm not sure I think neither of us take
it seriously enough to want to engage it
well I would say I in my experience you
can recognize heterodox thinkers because
if you come up with something that's
called the hard problem in a quadrant
that they are interested in they'll tell
you that's not a hard problem then
they'll tell you what they think the
answer is and they'll say the real hard
problem is and then they'll point to
something else so I think this is a
classic example of that so it's a move
I've made myself I should say alright do
I need to wear a mask if I just go for a
walk in my neighborhood and don't come
within 10 yards of anyone I don't
and it's certainly breathing fresh air
is very good for you I know that you
know if you are on narrow trails that
are sometimes frequented by runners and
runners are less likely to be wearing
math
and they are they should they have a
higher responsibility to be wearing
masks and a vulnerability they have both
a higher vulnerability but they are also
much more likely to spread what they've
got to other people because they are
experiencing greater respiratory
activity and so if you are if you are
likely to be sharing trails with runners
and not all the runners in your in the
area are likely to be masked you might
need to mask to be careful but I mean on
the walk that I took with our dog this
morning you know there's plenty of space
to get away from people when you do run
into them and neither I nor the dog
we're wearing a mask I would actually
say I mean I realize I'm going to get
annoying by continuing to raise the same
point over and over again but that's
part of the virtue of this solution
right you put it around your neck you
don't put it up but if somebody's coming
the other way maybe you do or if you're
walking up behind somebody because
you're gonna pass them you're passing
through a cloud of what they've exhaled
now that said this is a we have to have
a kind of adult conversation about this
I think a lot of people are carrying
around the model tell me what it is that
will make me perfectly safe and then
I'll do it that's not what you should be
thinking the fact is you know you could
wear a diving bell that would be safe
right but you're not going to wear a
diving though frankly all of us could be
wearing the kind of respirators that one
wears when you're applying paint we're
not doing it it would provide greater
protection but the point is the cost of
wearing such a thing is so high that
it's not in the right place you're much
better off managing the risk at some
tolerable level and basically my point
about the bandanas is it's a very
tolerable level you can wear it you
don't have to have it up you can put it
up on the fly
it doesn't broadcast a medical message
so anyway there's a lot to be said for
it and if it needs augmentation this
some of you will know what these are
these are shop towels right shop towels
there was never a run on these things
if you take a shop towel and you feel
that you're in a city to buy these when
you couldn't buy paper towels yeah if
you're in a situation that's maybe more
hazardous than going to the grocery
store you can put a shop towel in here
fold it right back up and put it right
back on and now you have a much more
effective barrier so anyway I think the
bottom line message is figure out how
the stuff is transmitted you're not
gonna have a perfect model because none
of us do but if you have a decent model
then you can answer your own question if
you're gonna go walking when nobody else
is out you probably don't need anything
but the cost of having a bandanna or
something else around your neck that you
can pull up when you do encounter
somebody I mean a it sends the signal
every time I go out people look at me
and I look at them and I can tell that
we're kind of thinking are you being
irresponsible or are you being careful
and so anyway even just having the
object that tells them I didn't do this
lightly all right I'm going out and I'm
being deliberate about it is is
important and that is a that is a
physical a visual indicator in the way
that the masks that my mother has made
for me that I am now wearing when I'm
out I put them in my pocket before I
wear them you know until I run into a
situation when they're still fresh
before they are have been used and in
need of being laundered they're not
visible which means that if I were to
see anyone you know what I'm driving
when I'm driving to the store they're
not visible and it doesn't do the same
job yep it doesn't but you know I think
I guess one of the things that I'm
seeing is I'm seeing people
experimenting yep and that you know it
took weeks but people are now showing up
improvising and they're discovering what
works and so anyway it's a good question
but I would say understand what the
argument is about how this is being
transmitted and then be rational right
it's as you know how the virus infects a
cell that's a highly technical question
how the virus gets into your lungs
that's not a highly technical question
so that's the question that you're faced
with when you when you go out good
figures indicate a much lower rate of
infection and also lower death rate from
kovat 19 in countries that still have a
BCG vaccine program for tuberculosis why
do you think that is this we saw this
briefly in between the two live streams
and I don't I did not assess whether or
not the claim is true that there are
lower we've did lower rates of infection
and lower death rates in countries that
still have this vaccine but this is this
older TB vaccine the one that leaves
like a circular mark and so here here I
cheated I looked it up it's the only one
that we did this for that we managed to
see in between these and without knowing
if this claim is true I will say that
there is apparently reported in science
in the last couple of weeks for
countries that are ramping up to explore
whether or not this vaccine which seems
to can convey that's not quite the right
word not just specific immunity for TB
but a wider immunity may actually be
effective against the novel coronavirus
so that that speaks not at all to
mechanism except that there is some kind
of more general immunity that this very
old uh vaccine seems to seems to convey
and it is actually in it in research
phase right now so I would add a caveat
here though which is the fact even if
the fact is true as stated it doesn't
suggest in this case that the TB vaccine
is causal of the differential likelihood
of infection it could be in fact it
sounds plausible enough but the problem
is if this is a holdover vaccine then
surely the countries that still use it
are united by more than just the simple
use of that vaccine they will be
probably socioeconomically similar they
will have similar decision-making
mechanisms and budgets per capita
for for medicine and all so you have
heard that correlation does not imply
causation when people claim that it
drives me crazy because correlation does
imply causation when there's a
pre-existing hypothesis that connects
the two but in the absence of a
pre-existing hypothesis correlation does
not imply causation which means that the
pattern that the T V TB vaccine seems to
be correlated with greater immunity to
kovat 19 is an observation that
observation is now in need of a test and
it's and the tests are being rolled out
it looks like and I would say that there
are other tests which we could figure
out very quickly which would be if you
do a pairwise comparison of individuals
who don't live in those countries who
did have this vaccine versus didn't have
this vaccine well within those countries
either way pairwise pairwise within
country within culture within broad
socio-economic and cultural experience
did and did not have the vaccine yep
what are what are the outcomes that's
true so I and I had assumed everybody
was vaccinated in these countries but
even if that's true people who've
immigrated in would maybe not have had
them and we could compare those two
populations but anyway the prediction is
if the vaccine is causal then it doesn't
matter where you are the presence of the
vaccine will be protective in the
absence of the vaccine will cause you to
be vulnerable and we should be able to
read that actually very very quickly
without running a new experiment just by
simply finding individuals who are
otherwise similar and comparing the two
population this is about collecting
numbers that already exist yeah yeah
where does darkness go when you switch
off the light I think this means I think
there's a typo where does darkness go
when you switch on the light right in
which case I think I've got this go for
it it goes behind you am I wrong about
that it goes behind you or you can't see
it but what if I'm looking behind you oh
then it goes behind both of us whose
dream is this it would have to be mine
it's safe all right
yes dr. Weinstein go back on Joe Rogan I
thought you're going to point out your
brilliant telomere discovery but we but
you mentioned the Biden paradox no
matter love you and dr. hangings
discussions we need solutions thank you
both I don't know how to answer this one
yeah
could you outline your approach to game
be the only elaboration of the concept
of have been able to find online is
Daniel shocking burger on the portal
well I can say this I this isn't the
right place to try to do an elaborate
thing but game B is the idea that our
system because it is so fragile requires
a change what I have called a
revolutionary change without revolution
and that that would produce a safe
sustainable fair alternative system that
is non utopian utopianism being the road
to hell in order to get there it would
have to be competitively superior to our
system in other words this is not
something that could be a poem posed
from above it would have to be something
that effectively caught on because it
worked for people it wins within the
structures of game a right it is
superior to game a in game A's terms
beyond that I would say I don't think
anybody including me should be providing
game B proposals I think the idea is
that game B is an idea it's a concept of
sort of the minimum requirements of a
design and then all of us ought to be
free below that level to propose
something that might reach those
objectives I have laid out a basic
version of this in my 4th frontier talk
you can look that one up online it's on
your website it's on the website the 4th
frontier thinking has come a long way
since then so there's more to say about
what a 4th frontier world might look
like so that's also the final chapter of
our book its fourth frontier
fourth frontiers final chapter of our
books so stay tuned it's an important
conversation but that's really what it
is at this point and I'm interested to
see as many people who understand the
necessity of a game B world and
the kind of game theory that would go
into architecting such a thing I'm
interested in hearing as many of these
proposals as possible likely if there is
a viable way forward it will involve
elements from the best proposals and
there will be sort of a chimeric game be
proposal ultimately that's what I'd love
to see and there's not going to be a
blueprint or roadmap
yeah it's going to be seeking the
adaptive Foothill in order to climb a
peak we can navigate there we can't
spell it out beforehand okay would you
consider doing a thorough online biology
class greetings from Norway that is the
only kind of biology class we would
consider thorough thorough yes
yeah whereas I read that and thought I
much I would do thorough just like I
never want to write a general biology
textbook but biology through various
evolutionary lenses yes perhaps yeah
it's for the class I would say we would
do a thorough we would be interested in
doing a thorough class probably it's not
thorough biology class because frankly
that's impossible biography is the
largest subject by virtue of the
unparalleled complexity in biology
relative to every other field so it's
impossible to be thorough but you can
pick a topic and do you know what we
understand so far kind of thing is urine
sterile if you have yes is the short
answer on that one if you have no means
to disinfect the hands would urine work
in a pinch thanks for the videos be well
no no so I would I'm gonna go first no
you're an is sterile but no it's not
going to disinfect your hands it being
sterile doesn't mean it's a disinfectant
it's soap and alcohol will disable the
virus for different reasons but urine
being itself sterile just means that it
doesn't have the capacity presumably to
infect you with anything new but it
doesn't mean that it can disinfect you
so the difference between sterile and
sterilizing yeah that's right actually
so the reason that I am a little
hesitant about saying anything so clear
is that I believe that the salt at least
in
urine actually does have the capacity to
to do some sterilization and I believe
them the Masai who are herders in in
East Africa who mostly eat meat and milk
yeah I mean blood and milk well they eat
they eat meat blood and milk is a famous
beverage they drink but in any case I am
I'm really hoping I didn't get the
particular culture wrong but I think it
is the Maasai who do utilize the urine
of their cows to sterilize their hands
now that doesn't say that it works
against any particular virus but my
guess would be so like before before
they're milking the cows maybe something
like that you know if I'm recalling it
correctly the cow is peeing and that's
an opportunity to go sterilize your
hands so I mean it's in a very dry
habitat yeah so the water is limiting
water is limiting opportunity strikes
when it does yeah you know if you have
no means to disinfect your hands would
we urine work in a pinch one of my
responses is if you're in a situation
where that is really the issue they
think it might be better to drink rather
than use it to clean your hands Wow
yeah I'm not going to touch that
literally or figuratively but I would
say this you have other options with
respect to sterilizing your hands so for
example if I was caught really with no
if I thought I had touched kovat 19a
concentrated as far as the virus star's
Cove - yeah if I thought I had contacted
it and I didn't have any water
I would probably seek you know if there
was sand that'd be great right
you can desiccate the virus into
oblivion you can physically rub it so
that the particles would stick to the
sand and drop away dirt
be used to work there's a lot of
richness in dirt that could be used to
bind things now it does have a lipid
surface layer the virus not dirt so the
lipid is nonpolar which means it's not
going to be as effective at sticking to
a lot of the organic materials in the
soil but nonetheless if you were to get
your hands really dirty and then rub
away that dirt chances of the virus
remaining both on you and intact enough
to function
I would imagine are pretty darn low and
after having rubbed your hands
thoroughly in dirt for a while you're
less likely to touch your face with them
that is true and that's the other thing
as I was I was gonna say is if I thought
I had contacted it I would do what I
could to dislodge it to gum up the
surface of the virus and then I would be
very careful about not touching any part
of me that could be infected and at some
point I did encounter water or the thing
would no longer be viable by virtue of
the amount of time oh also UV light go
outside sunlight that's a really good
antiviral in this case yeah although it
takes a while it seems how long I don't
know and the type of UV that is most
effective doesn't get through our
atmosphere so UVC is the is the most
quickly acting viral destroyer all right
it'd be interesting to know how long one
had to expose their skin to sunlight in
order to to effectively neutralize the
virus I agree I've seen conflicting
accounts under what circumstances would
it actually be beneficial for a virus to
kill the host in order to get into the
future further mm-hmm well let's take a
model it's not a virus
it's a prion but the disease kuru was
transmitted this this is a prion that
creates a encephalopathy in the brain
that was transmitted I think the story
is that it was transmitted to
women who were ceremonially preparing
bodies of the dead and I think eating
brains this is Papua New Guinea Papua
New Guinea and so anyway obviously in
the case of this prion the fact that it
was resident in brain tissue and that
the person needed to die and have their
brain consumed in order to be
transmitted to the next person death is
a part of the strategy and actually we
know a lot of stories
cordyceps fungus is transmitted a fungus
that spreads by infecting often ants you
know is it and causing them to behave in
such ways a bunch of hymenopteran ants
bees and wasps and causing them to climb
into the canopy and then as their body
becomes totally infected with the
cordyceps the spores basically emerge
from the corpse of the body and maybe
it's picked up by birds which then [ __ ]
it out and then they spreads into more
yeah after in something it's a
complicated story but I think I think in
that case to spread the host does end up
having to die again not a virus to
fungus yeah so I think I think what we
can generally say is that if there is a
plausible route for a pathogen to get
from one critter to the next critter
that involves death nature will have
found it multiple times just don't
underestimate the creativity of the
evolutionary force because it finds it's
like water it finds the cracks and so I
don't have a viral example but that's
not to say we couldn't come up with one
yeah when will we know if the virus
spread through aerosol and why do they
tell people using a mask isn't effective
if there are no data why do you use only
water to clean vegetables but use a soap
for hands so there's three questions
when will we know if the virus is spread
through aerosol I think we do know this
now and in fact I think of the very
first live stream I said it did and then
I saw comment because it's the only live
stream where we were actually seeing the
comments
and I was reminded oh no we don't think
it does well as of this week or so now
we think it does and we being you know
the scientific and medical establishment
thinks it does spread through aerosol
so that's one thing I'd also say if I
heard that it didn't spread through
aerosol I would strongly suspect
something was wrong with data I'm just a
simple fact of this being closely
related to common cold viruses the fact
that it's resident in the lungs there
are all kinds of reasons to think that
aerosol would be the obvious way for
this to be transmitted yeah why did they
tell people using a mask isn't effective
if there are no data I feel like we've
beaten that one a lot we've talked about
it a fair bit you know it feels
unconscionable but it happened and why
do you use only water to clean
vegetables but use a soap for hands it's
a very good question well I must say my
behavior on this front has changed and
it's hard for me to remember but we buy
organic fruits and vegetables and so in
general I've been very cavalier about
washing them because by and large what's
going to be on them isn't a hazard in
the case of kovat 19 I'm very much aware
that these things have sat in a
supermarket where people are walking
they're touching them they're coughing
and so my assumption is that that's a
very highly likely place for me to
encounter a virus that I didn't know was
there because I didn't go out you know
for example so every piece of fruit that
I eat now I wash it with soap so well if
it's if it's an apple for instance but
if it's citrus its it comes with its own
casing right so do you wash citrus as
well I I'm not as religious about it but
I'm close because to touch it and peel
it runs the risk that I will you know
just like there's no Salmonella inside
of an egg but the shell is almond Ella
we'll get into the egg as you break the
shell I would say it's the same it's the
same thing so I would say the you know
soap is your friend in this case soap
your washing machine your dishwasher all
of these things are mechanisms whereby
you can easily sterilize whatever kovat
19 you have on whatever it is out of
existence and in the case of fruit it's
a pretty or fruit and vegetable
it's you know if you're cooking the
vegetables it's a probably not that
necessary
I mean this is I do a lot more cooking
of vegetables than you do so I've been
preparing you know peppers which our
boys love fresh I wash peppers not in
hot water because if you're eating fresh
peppers you don't really want them to
have been heated but I do wash them and
so cucumbers in appealing which I
normally wouldn't necessarily be you
know always peel cauliflower it's gonna
be cooked in the oven for a long time we
have you know or fried whatever but if
it's going to be if it's going to
experience high heat for long periods of
time you don't need to bring soap to it
but if you're going to be eating it raw
yeah you really need to think about it
and the question is exactly right yep
where are we I don't know
does Oh does this hemoglobin hypothesis
explain why certain blood types appear
to be more at risk
good well because it involves virus
entering Wow actually it cannot I hope
I'm right about this but I've got to be
it cannot reproduce itself I don't think
it can reproduce itself in red blood
cells because red blood cells are
enucleated so it's the hemoglobin well
this is a question which I'm sure I
should know the answer to but how do red
blood cells they are produced by other
tissues so they're not might they don't
undergo mitosis correct so they are
produced by other tissues and then ever
yeah yeah they can't in mammals in birds
but the point is because they don't have
a nucleus they are not doing I believe
they do not have any of the machinery
necessary to do the viral work and
therefore the invasion of these cells to
get to the hemoglobin molecules must be
some other process unfolding so anyway I
think the answer to your question is it
potentially plays in we don't know how
but it is certainly worth thinking about
the antigens on the surface of those
cells that's where the [ __ ]
blood groups and the the rhesus factor
come from that those things might be
critically important in terms of how the
virus gets into those cells you
mentioned you had things in place for
the collapse of systems what were they
also what worries you mark Ovid 19r a
heightened Cold War with China I don't
remember what the mention of having
things in place for the collapse of
systems I said we've caught a little off
guard because when I moved we didn't
take a lot of stuff with us you know the
problem is we didn't take a lot of stuff
with us we also live in different
circumstances here in Portland than we
did in Olympia and so some of the stuff
wasn't relevant some of the stuff
changed in priority but to give you one
example that maybe will satisfy him we
had a pretty deep stock of air powered
tools the thought about air powered
tools was that in the absence of
electricity which drives the compressor
you can drive the compressor with
something like a bicycle hooked up to
the to the pump with a belt we got rid
of that stuff because we have no place
to put it but that meant that whatever
planning was based on air powered tools
is no longer viable on the other hand
the kind of collapse
that requires you to be using air
powered tools to solve problems that's a
pretty deep level of collapse that we're
not seeing anything remotely like it in
the circumstance at least not yet so it
doesn't come up but it could but what's
your markup at 19 or a heightened cold
war with China I must tell you I'm
worried about a heightened cold war with
China I'm worried about a hot war with
China I'm worried about all sorts of
things let's just be clear about this
kovat 19 is a human tragedy the costs
ongoing could be very very large
especially if we can't figure out how to
benefit and it just starts to circulate
annually or all the time
that's going to be very bad for us on
the other hand there does and we have to
be very careful to distinguish between
pre-symptomatic cases and non
symptomatic cases some of the
pre-symptomatic stuff are people who
haven't gotten sick yet but they will
and some of it is people who don't get
sick I may have been one of those people
maybe I had it when Heather had what she
had or maybe I didn't but the fact that
many people seem to get covert 19 and do
not get symptoms says that if this thing
got completely out of control
it would still leave a large fraction of
the human population intact the tragedy
would be immense but in terms of the
threat it poses to us it is not an
existential threat in and of itself on
the other hand the chaos that it could
cause for example a war of one sort or
another with China hot or cold could
become an existential threat without too
much difficulty and so that worries me
more because the there is no limit to
the downside I agree
many diseases diagnosis idiopathic my
dad is a very low cholesterol man had a
massive four artery blockage do we know
how the percentage of idiopathic Kovach
cases young healthy good lung health
compares to other diseases so idiopathic
is just fancy medical speak for we don't
know what causes it basically I don't
think I don't know I don't think Brett
knows and I don't know if if we know how
the percentage of Kovac and I'm not sure
this is exactly what we do Pathak means
here but you know how the percentage of
cases in which you have no underlying
conditions and you're young and you're
healthy and you're fit how that compares
to other diseases you just have to
control for a lot of stuff you have to
control for I mean maybe the comparison
is flu really you know you can't compare
it to something like cancers or
Parkinson's or you know there's just a
lot of diseases that you couldn't
compare to because because there are too
many things that are different so I must
say I'm not sure exactly what the
question means but I would say there is
an off
a lot of territory that remains largely
unexplored about managing whatever
circumstance you're in right managing
your circumstance can mean lowering your
likelihood of being infected it can mean
if you are infected lowering the degree
to which you are symptomatic and the
degree to which you spread it to others
and really the dire thing is that you
kick over into that third category that
we talked about in the livestream where
you need intensive intervention because
probably you are starving of oxygen and
that's stressing all of your your
tissues at once and you know it could
compromise your heart your lungs but in
any case we know that people who end up
in that third category are in very dire
straits where is the high-quality wisdom
on should you become sick how do you
stay out of that third category how much
do we know about that and I must say
maybe somebody knows but the information
has not percolated to me it's all been
focused on the epidemiology how you
avoid getting infected in the first
place and the information hasn't been
all that great there but I would love to
know about the how to stay out of the
the crisis category yeah I mean I've
seen some numbers around it's more
people than you think who are young or
have no underlying conditions who end up
hospitalized or very sick but the thing
here that I have no idea how to do is
compared to to what diseases you know
what would be the right comparison to
make here yeah next question are there
any beneficial viruses that is
beneficial to us god there must be why
wouldn't why wouldn't there be at some
level in which the strategy is is one of
effectively collaboration in which they
they win and do and so do we
I can't think of any at the moment
though I think part of the problem here
is that if they were beneficial viruses
you might not know that they were viral
in other words if if a virus was
benefiting us and unambiguously it might
find that it became integrated into our
germline genome and then you might not
know that that gene had moved
horizontally into into that position
there might be ways of figuring it out
but my guess would be to the extent that
such things have evolved we will be late
to find them because we will think of
them as as our genes rather than genes
that came to us in some way good this so
just this is a comment this is a link to
a censored article on how h CQ is
hydroxychloroquine and z-pak that's 2
through max also know so through myosin
are able to cure the CCP virus which is
not what it's called saris Cove - what
we're referring to here it has to do
with the fact that the virus is
attacking the hemoglobin in red blood
cells okay check out that link what can
we expect from the Cova 19 outbreak
given the experiences for the Spanish
flu can we expect to see another
outbreak equal or worse when the next
flu season starts similar to 1918 quite
possibly but no guarantees we talked a
bit in I don't know maybe livestream -
about the possibility of seasonality the
idea being so I don't know a ton about
the history of the flu in the years in
the for 1918 but for sure flu existed in
humans for many many many years before
that whereas that you know the
distinction here is that we're dealing
with an enemy a virus that has no
history with humans and and we have no
history with it and has no history with
us before six months ago so there is no
history of patterning evolving such that
ok it's gonna disappear in the warmer
months and come back in the cooler
months or could be the opposite it
couldn't you know there could be any
number of types of security but it our
relationship with it is so new that it's
very hard to predict what might happen
it could have had a relationship with
its prior host that would produce a kind
of see now it's not clear how that would
work
a couple points there there is some
evidence that the Spanish flu was made
worse
by was it early and set treatments
aspirin possibly I didn't know that
anyway we were seeing an echo of that in
this epidemic it's worth thinking about
although in this epidemic there's no
I've seen no compelling evidence that
aspirin has been thought to be dangerous
but the other end says the newer acids
things like ibuprofen and such or have
been thought no one is officially making
this claim at this point but have been
thought to be a bad combination with
regard to sickness lots arts Cove - I've
seen the non aspirin NSAIDs claimed to
do damage on the basis of evidence that
I actually find compelling I've seen the
same argument made for avoiding aspirin
but I've seen zero evidence that it's
actually known to do hon it's just
listed in with the other ones because
it's it's in this category and I mean
this is this is a problem with this type
of thinking or it's like oh I have a
category and I have evidence that all of
these new drugs may cause harm I'm gonna
put the other thing which is a much
older drug and that in into that list
because it fits in this category that I
have yeah
in fact aspirin you know aspirin is very
old it it it comes out is it willows
yeah it's something which you willow
bark yeah it it is derived from
something that humans have been using as
a municipal for thousands of years which
is far different from a drug that was
dreamed up in a lab within the few
decades and the dosages again I hope I'm
getting the story right for the dosages
that were being used around the Spanish
flu were super high absolutely
astonishingly high and therefore
probably destructive in their own right
let's see Oh what can we so the other
thing about Spanish flu is its flu and
flu has this mechanism for switching
components and so because this because
coronavirus is function in a different
way there also
but non retroviruses that they don't
have they don't have the capacity to
switch up antigens in the same way that
said they because of what we talked
about in the livestream and the fact
that they appear to have this error
correction mechanism which we are
arguing is something that could be
turned on or turned off it's possible
they have some other mechanism but
really I would just I guess what you
said up front is is probably the right
answer to the question we don't know
that they will have seasonality there's
reason to think some seasonality will
emerge from people's change in behavior
but there's very little reason to think
that the seasonality will emerge from it
being wired to go dormant during the
summer the way other things seem to be
okay I think we need to speed it up we
got I don't know how many more questions
we have Zack but we're gonna start
trying to answer these much more quickly
okay so does the error correcting
mechanism so is the error correcting
mechanism a good thing or bad thing with
regard to how we deal with kovat 19 oh
it's probably a good could go either way
it's probably a good thing as it
probably stabilizes the virus so that it
is not rapidly changing which means that
it lower rate of mutagenesis so easier
to target if we can get a vaccine that
functions against it it will not morph
out from under us it will remain steady
so that's why if it could turn that
mechanism off it might evade but but
also it's an error correcting mechanism
that's that we currently think it is
what else can it do you know can it can
it is it is it a multi-part factory that
can produce all sorts of things besides
fixing mutations who knows don't know if
we got rid of influenza would people
without immunity to it die if it came
back mmm some people would as some
people die of influenza every year as
many people die of influenza every year
but would it be more all right yeah I
only suspect so yeah probably because
you have a series of
counters with the flu you have you have
a head start on chasing it down when you
get infected yeah I'd be very good
Braddock ating it completely would make
a reintroduction potentially more deadly
yes yep my interpretation of masks don't
work is that it is false
literally false but metaphorically true
regular people with masks will still rub
their eyes or the equivalent reserving
the supply for professionals is
important yes and now I think the thing
is I've seen so much this year where
people are essentially arguing that that
complexity is something normal folks
can't handle so we have to dumb stuff
down I don't think this is true I think
we're now watching people level up and
the fact is they could be weeks ahead of
where they are if we had been straight
with them up front so I certainly don't
think we know that people couldn't
handle the raw truth if we simply gave
it to them and frankly I think it's
immoral to assume that they can't and to
deliver them these kinds of fictions
this is not a thousand years ago this is
modern times we have the internet we can
talk each other through this let's be
honest with each other about where we
are what works what resources are too
limited where they should go and what
the rest of us should be doing and let's
do it now yeah so I'm going to come back
to the next question but two questions
later is actually relevant to this so
I'll just go there seems that the spread
and cultures wear masks of the social
norm has been significantly mitigated it
may be spurious of course because there
are other correlated factors but I think
this is right
and we have not even begun to untangle
all of the other factors yet but but it
it seems like a good initial observation
at any rate and so then the question
before that was can you talk more about
cats on kovat 19 mm-hmm yeah so we were
going to I don't have the article with
me here today but piece came out
sometime in the last week we can have
suggesting that it's not saris Cove to
is not transmissible to dogs although
you would independently found two cases
of dogs I might have had it
but the cats and ferrets apparently can
can get kovat 19 and then more recently
yet we have this case of the tiger at
the Brooklyn zoo some some zoo
that's not forgotten which I can't
assume is some New York zoo and that's
about all we know at least that's that's
about all I know at this point is that
unfortunately it seems that two of our
domesticated partner animals can get it
potentially from us and potentially then
within within each other you know spread
it to each other so I think this is
really to be expected yeah the fact is
these coronaviruses seem to live in bats
and find their way into other creatures
and what that says is that they are
generalist when it comes to what what
sorts of animals that they can make a
profit with so anyway we should expect
it what I what I haven't seen is that
cats or dogs have been then spreading it
to people yeah we haven't seen in that
direction we haven't seen that asymmetry
yeah I mean it's not to say it's not
possible but we haven't seen any
evidence of that right and so that will
be a very positive thing if that's not a
common mode of transmission yeah seems
of the SPRO we already read that one
should we petition public parks to be
reopened do you think the closure of
public lands and parks is an example of
tyranny on the part of the executives
who have issued these closures well I've
been pretty clear how I feel about this
I think public parks should be reopened
I understand that there are a lot of
people who don't know how to behave
themselves once they go out on mass and
they've been cooped up but that that
being able to experience being outside
and in landscapes that are that have
fresh air and sunlight and nature and
and animals besides humans to experience
is going to be absolutely critical in
terms of being able to
last psychologically through these this
quarantine and lockdown is the closure
and example of tyranny on the part of
the executives I wouldn't use that word
but I see why it's being used
I think it's overreach I think it's
confusion I think it is misunderstanding
what the point of social distancing is I
think it fails to recognize that that
there is an effective viral load and
that being staying away from people and
presumably you know especially if like I
said like we said earlier if you're on
trails that are narrow and you may run
into someone who's running the other way
they should be masked and it would be
better if you could be masked in
response weeks ago I was in the hundreds
acre park near our house and three guys
ran past me with no masks on breathing
heavily and I thought that's that's not
good like that is that is not what you
want when you're going out into nature
but other than that what I saw mostly
was a lot of people mostly older who
were outside enjoying the landscape and
presumably they're not now and that is a
hundred percent making them more at risk
of getting sick from other things and
making them more at risk of falling into
psychological disarray as well
there is tyranny I don't think the park
thing is it there is other stuff
legislative stuff that yes much more
credibly tyrannical but this is another
opportunity why aren't we talking about
how we can go back to using parks in
public lands safely frankly people are
talking about our predicament almost
full time we can talk about how it is
that one uses a park in the situation
maybe there's no trash collection maybe
you carry out what you bring in maybe
there's a certain number of feet you
need to stand in the park and it isn't
what we can infer from the supermarket
but why aren't we having the discussion
yeah there there are enough of us with
experience in the back country who know
who know how to inform others of things
like Leave No Trace and it's not to say
that it will be perfect and one thing I
will say is that on these walks that
I've been taking with the dog I have
seen an unfortunate uptick of finding
piles of dog poo that we're
left by our dog because I can we clean
it up so that seems like a failure that
is happening now that I never would have
run into you know three months ago
people would have always cleaned it up
and somehow there was social enforcement
that no longer exists but it seems to me
that people are absolutely educated have
our parks reopened without explaining
exactly the next question without
explaining exactly what the fourth
frontier is please answer the following
is it a laid out plan or more of a
thought experiment and can
all-encompassing plan be developed from
where does it have to evolve I think we
went there right yeah it it is a I think
the core inside of the fourth frontier
is that we cannot describe it in advance
what we can do is algorithmically
navigate to it so one needs to spell out
something that is viable but the attempt
to make it precise upfront would doom it
so it's not a thought experiment it
really is about where we all ought to go
together how we how we architect that
system but it will not be done from a
blueprint it will be done as a matter of
navigation on what we would call the
adaptive landscape if now why 86 a
youtuber whose content has mainly
focused on China is correct and I don't
know what this is so that's a that's an
if what do we do if this was something
released accidentally or purposefully by
Wuhan and the Communist Party of China
should China face any repercussions and
how it's a big question I think that's
very different if it was purposefully
versus accidentally yeah it's a lot of
questions I think maybe we'll probably
come back to that we've touched on this
before but we I mean if it was
purposefully done it's mass murder yeah
right if it was accidental then it is
obviously something that must never
happen again and we have to navigate it
but just the two questions aren't even
in the same ball if it was accidental it
could have it could have happened and I
won't say just as easily because there
are different structures in place in
different countries but it could have
happened in any country that has
virology labs which is certainly you
know most most industrialized countries
if not all in a
july's countries on the planet things
can escape
well they need they need not to and yet
they still do I used to handle bats as a
matter of my graduate work I don't think
those bats were particularly likely to
to house a human transmissible virus
that could cause a pandemic like this as
a result of the fact that they were
roosting in small groups under leaves
rather than in caves where the
epidemiology is different but
nonetheless every scientist who's
handling wild animals is running some
risk of transmitting this stuff to the
human population how we navigate that so
that it doesn't happen again from some
other source that's a very valid
question but people are handling animals
and that's putting humanity at risk and
we need to figure out how not to
overreact but to deal with those
potential conduits so that humanity is
protected from this happening so we're
gonna try to speed it up how many more
do we have say ok we were ok we're gonna
have to go faster as a result of the
number of questions we've been asked is
that the one we're at the one you've got
highlighted now yes ok thank you what is
our path forward through this as a
society can we hope for the end of
capitalism and what might a better
system look like the problem is you're
not gonna be able to define capitalism
can you hope for the end of markets no
can you hope for the end of a predatory
system that is increasingly ruled by
rent seekers let's hope so because if we
can't we're unfortunately doomed by the
product of what they do does human
muscular weakness relative to similarly
sized mammals along with linguistic and
tool-making capacity imply that we are
designed in quotes to transcend biology
through synthetic upgrades of our
biological functions no no although the
two things may travel together we became
very clever apes that can wield tools
rather
then muscle and at the same time so the
two things co-evolved yeah we are we are
not fastest or the best climbers or the
best swimmers or the best anything but
we are extraordinary journalist
generalists who have begun to expand
outside of our physical bodies long
since begun through linguistic
tool-making consciousness lots of other
things and we are therefore experiencing
upgrades but we aren't transcending and
they are not necessarily synthetic next
question since our use of animals causes
the vast majority of pandemics extreme
damage to the planet depletion of
resources and unimaginable suffering is
it time to start mostly leaving animals
alone it's too simple it's it's it's too
simple a solution we've addressed the
question of wet markets in an earlier
livestream well and you know we have
animals with which we have a very long
history we know what diseases they carry
we understand how to manage those
diseases and these creatures are have
effectively become our partners and I
know lots of people think it's mean to
eat animals but the fact is driving them
extinct isn't better so we should be
limiting the amount of animal meat that
we eat because it's environmentally
destructive but should it be zero no
there's no reason to for it to be zero
it's not a healthy diet it's much easier
to be healthy if you eat some meat and
so there is a rational middle ground
here and the extremes neither of them
are wracked yeah are we doing better by
cows or bison you know cows by almost
every metric some anecdotal reporting on
the type of coronavirus death includes
references to people being fat obese or
unfit low vo2 max of obese people
related to hemoglobin hypothesis
question mark yeah yep could well be
harder to pump oxygen through a
abnormally large body yes yes
simple answer your question any theories
and what we haven't heard anything
definitive on patient zero what
advantages could be had from withholding
that information they would be
hypotheses not theories but we've heard
a little bit about the possibility of
patient zero a woman who seems to have
disappeared from the lab in Wuhan I
can't imagine why it would be worth
without her body disappeared or well she
was an employee of the lab in Wuhan she
was at this story could be nonsense I'm
not in a position to assess it at all
all I can say is I've seen the claim
that there was a woman working in this
laboratory who many people take to be
patient zero and that she disappeared
her data was scrubbed from the website I
believe the government claims that she's
alive and well and doing fine and but
there's no evidence of her again I don't
know if that's a garbage story I've been
fed or not but what I do know is there
does seem to be a connection between the
lab in Wuhan and the studying of these
viruses that is very hard to ignore the
wet market connection seems tentative
the more you try to chase it down and so
there does seem to be a very likely
explanation which is that this thing
escaped as a result of a lab that wasn't
sufficiently careful and maybe the CCP
wishes us not to understand that and so
the cover story being a wet market
requires that there was no patient zero
in the lab maybe that's it but yes
withholding the information is criminal
the release the accidental release would
not be but hiding the information that
would allow us to figure out what
actually happened is certainly
tantamount to a crime if it isn't
actually one yeah you two are exactly
the kind of people that I want to hear
from at a time like this thank you for
doing it thank you
if I had a time machine and went back a
thousand years would my immune system
for all of my ancestors history of
viruses and I would be a superhero or
what I'd be completely unprepared for
that eras virus's question that's a
great question it would be neither
extreme there there are certainly new
things that have emerged that you
wouldn't be that that you were prepared
for now that you wouldn't need
preparation for back then but there
presumably also be older viruses that
have either been extirpated or have
changed so much that your modern
antibodies wouldn't do a good enough job
on dealing with the older ones yeah I
actually think it's kind of likely that
you know especially with their having
been bottlenecks in the human population
that some infections will have been lost
yeah and they might function like a
truly naive population encountering
smallpox right so a superhero with a few
kryptonite's yeah thank you for doing
these if you have time and want to
laughs check out our last video on
televangelists and code 19 what are your
thoughts on them they are highly
unlikely to be an effective remedy
non-scientific question I'm a former
academic can you speak to your vision of
hope for alternative scholarship and
educational forums and forums
this is this is something we've spent a
considerable time especially in the last
year a few years thinking about I'm not
sure that we can do my I just don't
think we have time right now
um we're overthinking education and
under thinking it at the same time the
fact is it's a normal thing we're built
to do it and our system that is designed
to deliver education in an economically
efficient fashion is obscene so we need
to remember what education is for it's
supposed to teach you how to think not
what to think and we need to build a
system that's capable of doing that
which means it's a system that has to
acquire and protect the kind of minds
who are actually in a position to
educate other people how to think
independently which is not something
that our current system does well often
it does the opposite so
I think the question in some sense if we
have the courage to see why our system
doesn't work it's a question that almost
answers itself what do we need in an
educational system we need a system that
educates and it's not that hard and in
the final part of your answer to that
you wrapped it back into scholarship
right that it's too often we have two
tiers in the modern academic setting
there are people who do research and are
mostly freed from teaching and we have
people mostly either adjunct Satar ones
at research universities or people who
are at liberal arts colleges who are
mostly teaching and who aren't
continuing to contribute new ideas and
that that division is toxic to a
functional system of higher ed thanks
professors thank you you're welcome
is a scenario of long telomere mice
biasing drug research negated by human
trials coming after if not why
absolutely not the reason is because
when you test things on mice you are
trading on the following idea that
pathologies that emerge after a long
term exposure to a drug will be mirrored
by pathologies in a mouse if you give
higher quantities of the drug you will
see those pathologies early in a mouse
if you then move on to human trials are
you gonna follow those humans that
you've administered this drug for the
next 50 years in order to figure out
whether their lifespans are shortened
and are you gonna hold the drug off the
market for those 50 years no you're not
so in effect our system is built to use
mice as a proxy for long term hazards
which those mice at least in their long
telomere form cannot do and then to use
humans in order to discover critical
short-term hazards so what I've said
repeatedly is our system is actually
pretty good at spotting very short term
critical hazards and it is very bad when
it comes to long term hazards that are
basically hidden by noise
can someone address the baby-boom that
will was that will result from this
pandemic the virus kills the non
breeding population
more more than younger people but not
exclusively of course and then density
I'm not sure what the last sentence
means but I'm not sure what how to
address the baby boom will address so it
will result there's a question about a
baby boom the baby boom that we call the
baby boom happened presumably because
people had held off reproducing during
World War two and then accelerated the
production of kids afterwards it is not
clear to me that that's the frame of
mind that people have at the moment
there's a question of what frame of mind
they ought to have and a question of
what frame of mind they do have but I am
NOT I don't think it's a simple
prediction that there will be a baby
boom in the aftermath I do think we need
to think about the interaction depending
upon how many people are killed by this
virus and how many people are
compromised it predicts very different
economic futures coming out of this
crisis and it would be worth thinking
about what those futures look like and
how we might prepared for them his AK is
52 the last one no okay
54 okay all right so I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go 52 up and then down to 54
because I can't see those watch America
first when Nicholas J Fuentes never
heard of it but I read it men's store
more than women do either if you know if
this reduces oxygen enough to account
for the discrepancy in severe cases yes
breathing reduces the need to cough I
mean I think snoring is often a kind of
sleep apnea which does indicate a
imperfect functioning of respiration
during sleep why men are more likely to
have that particular front of sleep
apnea I do not know but is is that may
be linked to the greater morbidities and
fatality rates among men than women here
possibly men are in general more fragile
as a result of a consequence of sexual
selection in this case you've got a
particular pathology that is
disproportionately
with mana it could be connected but I
would say there's that there's a whole
story that needs to be unpacked around
apnea
orthodontia oxygenation of the blood
potentially this virus and I don't think
we know enough about it but the
connection between these things is bound
to be interesting good now you got
people wondering yes very good
Pamela Olson again thank you she says
thank you supporting you how about a
smile and hand hold it is good to see
people touching since we can't so this
is the third time all right Brett still
reading because he's dyslexic yes yeah
sorry I didn't know when the hand hold
was supposed to start all right okay
this is all very important but where'd
you get that lamp hell yeah I have had
that lamp so long and I loved it but now
you all can love it and it has secrets
it has yet to tell so anyway yes we're
in it I got it that lamp predates me in
your life is that right yeah that lamp
came from a client I believe Duncan
parking meter was a client of my
father's and some wonderful person at
Duncan parking meter whose name I have
unfortunately forgotten sent me that
beautiful lamp and a genuine so that is
a genuine antique parking meter and he
also sent me a modern parking meter and
I had one crazy afternoon I'm a foreign
tinkerer and I took the parking meter
the other one and I removed one screw
and the thing blew into a million parts
and boy I was sweating bullets about
whether I would ever get the thing back
together I did get it back together at a
fully functional but so where is it I
don't know I've been wondering that at
what point did that one disappear I feel
like I met that one too but I don't it's
been a lot it's been many moves I don't
say that I'm pleased that this one has
survived everything we've been through
and is now making its debut on the
Internet
was it in the vehicle that burned up
with everything else we owned inside of
it it could
being yeah okay that's probably actually
what happened to it yeah no I was
talking about this one no this one was
not okay
okay so scroll down we're done with this
page I think all right we have a couple
more two more looks like hold on two
more questions
can we develop herd immunity against
kovat 19 probably we should not be
trying to do that yet the longer it is
before vast numbers of people get it the
more likely the virus and we will have
evolved a more stable relationship and
more likely yet is the likelier we are
as humans to have developed effective
medications to have understood what the
mechanisms of action are to therefore
know for instance what to do with
ventilators and when maybe to have a
vaccine all of these things so yes herd
immunity is hopefully a long-term answer
but that does not mean that we should
try to accelerate that process that
would be dangerous yeah I think we are
developing it but yeah the problem is it
comes at a very high cost at the moment
so anyway some of us you know we may be
immune as a result of you having it and
I may be having it yes mm-hmm
okay final question what do you see
happening to evergreen I don't know what
that question means to what do we see
happening at the moment is there you
know there was a state of the college
address in which the person in charge of
the financial disclosure said they had
about two years of reserves he then says
recently yeah John Carmichael number two
Carmichael yes I do
yeah well John Carmichael said they had
about two years left at the current burn
rate before they would go under he then
gave a couple of reasons that he was
hopeful the reasons were nonsense which
sounds like him too so anyway I think
evergreen is in dire circumstances this
was before now it was actually during
the early part of the epidemic so I
think what may have happened
but the Board of Trustee is a scheduled
of meeting which is widely thought to
maybe be about declaring bankruptcy
because many many small colleges
I mean Evergreen is unique in being a I
think unique at least very unusual in
being a public liberal arts college most
liberal arts colleges are private and
therefore have a larger amount of money
to depend on being public and liberal
arts puts it a particular risk pulling
the shenanigans to put it lightly that
it pulled in 2017 puts it at great risk
and then the fact that kovat 19 is
creating financial straits for a Crosse
higher ed across institutions of higher
ed means that this may well be the straw
well I think you I think it's almost
certain to kill the college the problem
from my perspective is that in order for
the world to get smarter the
consequences have to flow to the people
who screwed up you know too big to fail
is a reasonable argument because
institutions that are of a particular
nature when they fail hurt a lot of
innocent people but the people who steer
them into danger
should never be covered by too big to
fail in the case of Evergreen they bent
over backwards year after year to
preserve George bridges reputation why
he came there he made terrible decisions
they came back to haunt us absolutely
immediately would it had been so
terrible to say we do not have any
confidence in this man's leadership we
wish him well and to move on no they
kept him on board through the end of his
contract gave him some kind of bizarre
statement about his wisdom and courage
in the face of everything that he saw
and they sent him on his way I mean he's
still in he's still there but he's
through the end of the academic year at
which point they're gonna take him on as
a teacher as their furloughing other
people so that is in and of itself
insane but now the pandemic is going to
give them cover and they're gonna claim
that the college failed because you know
there was a long term trend where they
were losing students which yes was true
but that long-term trend had nothing to
do with the cliff they hit as a result
of bridges
herbal management of the place so don't
get us started like this yes this we do
want drinks in front of us for right
we'll get brutally honest and it is five
o'clock somewhere oh I'm sure it is in
fact it's even five o'clock it's five
o'clock here yeah okay we hit one more
question and then and then we're done
okay - potentially fatal viruses that
become endemic and populations who gain
near immunity or compatibility act as
unintentional bioweapons for that
population which attack potential
adversaries Guns Germs and Steel is that
story in spades yes
the fact is when the conquistadors came
to the new world they wielded smallpox
without even knowing that they were
doing it yeah that their guns knowing
full well what they were doing and
wielded smallpox unintentionally and in
many ways smallpox was the far more
effective killer and what's more if you
think about what happened next well I
should let me say they real did smallpox
unintentionally at first later they used
it as a bio weapon I think those stories
are apocryphal okay um they may have
wielded smallpox as a bioweapon by
giving small box infected blankets to be
I think that story is a part I just said
that I'm saying they may have I know
but okay so anyway I don't I don't think
that necessarily had to happen but
smallpox did some much of the heavy
lifting of conquering the new world and
then the Spanish looted it and how much
gold ended up in Europe that was
actually a new world gold and what
effect did that have first centuries
after on you know who ruled over whom so
anyway yes it is an unintentional
bioweapon as you say okay alright we
back on Friday we will see you for our
name Friday all right be well stay safe
everyone
you